hello welcome to this video playing and
deca and probably Stefano day as a share
no I'm never getting this right anyway
so we've got ass laughs I've been deform
then do that all that much recently
played lots of c-4 end and tried also
evil a little bit in recent games okay
so he tries to play with 92 before I
mean oftentimes this is possible not
sure about the specific position
yeah probably i can also do that night
before we a for this night is not really
on safe ground or maybe he's just
playing a for now and sorry a five of
course yeah on the other hand if I play
Knight to Bishop 32 I should really know
what the bishop in the night is if I
play Bishop 22 what's the big idea
checking doesn't help let's see I mean
this is threatening to window the full
piece so it's not just like a pawn
dropping or something I don't know what
he's doing now looks a bit awkward
well looks bad I don't really see a good
solution for black maybe there is one
but I don't see it know something went
wrong here yes it's possible but if I
take it and let's see okay this is this
what's the point so here what to do it's
not so easy for him to regain this pond
if I if I am careful them hmm but it's
also it's not possible to promote it I
guess c5 maybe it's as a plan 9797 b6
that that's lots of what he wants to do
so maybe this one having a look at this
porn
III 93 is also kind of interesting kind
of interesting yeah this this is
possible pretty interesting idea so this
one I guess you can go nite c2 which I
don't think that works again cooking the
one night f2 king at sea to take sage
one I don't think that this does work at
the end okay 93 that was the idea anyway
to get to get rid of this before split
zombie form okay so night takes or king
tails I think King takes actually night
on d2 I don't see what it is doing yes
my door detour doesn't make any sense on
King see through a 93 might come to a
four or something along these lines
maybe you can take these three Bishop
takes check on before and then rupee
eight that that probably works maybe he
should I mean 95 is definitely an idea
in this position so okay only this is
best yeah this is definitely okay right
we should be four it's okay for him and
then would be eight so he managed to
defend this position wow I didn't do
that
hmm interesting so I guess who yeah
let's speed up a little bit makes you
five more difficult and now yeah Luke c5
is actually interesting but I would have
a better place night that would be very
interesting actually okay night c 3 a 4
I want to play okay I hope that the
check out while Bishop h2 isn't isn't
serious and now it's a bit late for that
i get to a 4
yeah yeah with hindsight rook a one
would have been better but at the time I
was thinking I could maybe double on the
a file now this is not not relevant 56c
getting come to play maybe mm-hmm I took
like so much to trade a rook here but
maybe I have to okay will be 6f 95 I
look is seven mm-hmm I had the check and
go here and if it doubles here I have
the check on c5 shall think that that
I'm worried so much about the e-file
here now that i have a protected pass on
the B file rook e8 yeah I think Rupert
it too so that King c2 is possible and
a5 is just take just gets taken next
move check
you
check check black resigns yeah he had
equality he got to equality I mean the
opening didn't go all too well but he
definitely got to a position that was
defendable ok ok b5 the engine is
completely merciless understand I didn't
think about to shoot at five year why I
mean probably cause I thought I take a
five but the problem is that's really
very nice idea by the engine now I
cannot defend us and I cannot play here
because he takes takes and takes my poor
night so this was good for blackjack I
know yeah this is good for him hmm ok
it's nice also threatening oops no head
to take on d phone and this is the best
according to the engine this variation
with the slight edge from black now
no I think I would prefer black quite
clearly here but ok this is also
something yeah I don't know it's not
nice for white anyway so this I took it
and he still is okay yeah I believe this
was probably a right move because 1976
was annoying so you went here and he
surprised me thank you hear ya hear ya
be should be 48 justice ok right and
this this was not really necessary i can
go here and we'll be aid to pick it up
like this this and this and probably
this is equal I don't well well ok I
mean this is probably not equal not
straightaway this is tough to judge i
mean the point is not all that important
yet it's a double phone but he still has
some structural issues still 26 and so
on if i get this for example in that's
nice the engine gives white a slight
edge here maybe i'm not sure whether
this is clearly worse in comparison now
i get this night to a for it doesn't
just a very critical situation I don't
think that that this is something that
black can hold yeah and after 95 it's
definitely over but i was thinking
rookie seven and then I wasn't sure what
you do the engine plays in a forced
fashion as usual b7 don't quite
understand 9-piece nature and this
assesses check another's check but there
are checks here of course interesting
yeah so if you go see I have
that means the King has to go back and
then I can take I am ok that is indeed
clearly better for white ok I don't
think I would have seen that I think my
I was more thinking about this is a
simple move here trade one pair of rooks
so that in this position black cannot
invade i can give a check if he likes
but now he doesn't invade with the rooks
and i can continue this position which
is still very nice i've got this very
safe pawn and black has no worm no
activity check after that it's it's
fairly easy check down ok so we had
challenges chances to equalize there at
one point and he had a good position
actually out of the opening with this
night a six before I didn't see that
push a five resource ok guys thanks for
watching